Sigamos evaluando expresiones que tienen muchas
variables desconocidas,
en este caso nos dan "3x" más "3y" más "3z" igual a 1 y "12x" más "12y" más "12z",
¿a qué será igual?
Te voy a dar unos segundos para que pienses en esto.
Vamos a reescribir esta expresión que se
encuentra aquí factorizando el 12
y tenemos 12 veces "x" más "y" más "z".
Y puedes verificar distribuyendo el 12, que
obtenemos exactamente lo que está aquí.
Ahora veamos,
¿cuánto es 12 veces "x" más "y" más "z"?
Y pues la verdad, todavía no lo sabemos,
pero esta primera ecuación puede ser de utilidad.
Esta primera ecuación, también la podemos
escribir factorizando el 3
y entonces quedaría del lado izquierdo, tres veces "x" más "y" más "z" igual a 1,
lo único que hice fue factorizar.
Y ahora, para resolver, "x" más "y" más "z", puedo dividir ambos lados entre 3
y entonces me quedará "x" más "y"
más "z" es igual a 1/3.
Y ahora regresando a nuestra otra ecuación,
en vez de "x" más "y" más "z" puedo sustituirlo por 1/3
y vemos que todo se simplificó a 12 veces 1/3, que es lo mismo que 12 veces entre 3 que es igual a 4.
Intentemos una nueva.
En ésta nos dicen que "3a" más "5b" es igual
a 2 y nos preguntan,
¿"15a" más "15b" a qué será igual?
Te voy a dar unos segundos para que lo pienses.
Bueno, como en los ejemplos anteriores, yo
podría tomar esta expresión de aquí y reescribirla
como 15 veces "a" más "b" y si yo supiera
el valor de "a" más "b", ya estaría listo.
Y entonces, pues podríamos regresar a nuestra
primera ecuación, intentando reescribirla
en términos de "a" más "b", entonces si
yo factorizara el 3,
me quedaría como 3 veces "a", más 5/3 de "b",
lo cual no parece ayudar mucho.
Y de la misma manera, si yo quiero factorizar el 5 me va a quedar 5 veces 3/5 de "a" más "b" es igual a 2,
y como se puede ver, ninguna de estas dos resulta en la forma que queremos ver solo a "a" más "b".
Así que mejor escribimos, no tenemos suficiente
información para resolver.
Bueno, con suerte también te pareció interesante.